Hello BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Sky Blinding!
BAU BAU!
It's been a little while, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for our 127th episode!
We're so happy to be back!
Yeah, it's been a while!
Yeah, there's been a little bit of different programming going on.
It's a bit different than normal, huh?
But we're back for our 127th episode!
Thank you for waking up, Ruffians!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Well, for Ruffians who are just joining us for the first time today... Good morning!
Good morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Yeah!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Hashtag hashtag!
You like more huh?
FUWAMOCO.
More hashtag, hashtag.
I just had an idea.
Huh?
Can I down?
Okay.
My first idea of the day, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
I hope you have your first idea of the day soon.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, it's been about a week since the last FUWAMOCO Morning.
Yeah.
But there's been a lot of stuff going on.
Yes!
Let's take a look.
Actually...
What else do we have?
You know.
What?
What do you mean you know, Moco-chan?
Pero Sighting.
We've been holo-santos for a week, Ruffians!
I didn't see Pero really there that long.
Sighting, but...
Did you see all the Ruffians?
Let's take a look.
Okay.
De-den!
What?
What is this?
Huh?
A petal flower?
He's a baboon!
Yeah!
Baboon?
I don't know if I like the sound of that.
It sounds so cheerful though, no?
Maybe?
But, you know, Ruffians, well, you know they say it's not good to really pick flowers, right?
Without permission.
Yeah, because then somebody, they're gonna not be able to enjoy the flower.
It's only gonna be you who enjoys the flower, especially when they're not yours and stuff.
If they're not yours, that's one thing, but if you want to pick the flower and it's yours, then you're okay.
But, but, I feel like...
In this case, this is a special case for a friend!
You know, so, uh... Why don't you go ahead... Pick that flower!
Give it to someone who would really truly appreciate it, you know?
Someone like maybe...
Garbage can.
Why?
I guess at that point, it would be now a... It was a miracle of nature.
Yeah.
It was.
Past tense.
No petal flowers!
No, we don't need those.
BAU BAU!
Petal flower.
The least liked flower by FUWAMOCO.
Imagine getting a bouquet like that.
I don't want to imagine that.
That's really nasty.
That's a bouquet of flowers you give to your worst enemy.
Yeah.
I guess.
Ruffians, what do you think?
Yes?
You like a sexy flower?
Huh?
What flower?
A sexy flower.
We're talking about nasty flowers.
It's okay, forget it, forget it.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Look, we got distracted there.
But you know, there's been some really big important things going on since our last FUWAMOCO Morning.
So let's introduce some of them, shall we?
I'm sure you've heard Ruffians, but... Sure, but... Wow, some big important news is that... Wow.
Our very dear senpai, Amelia Watson of Holomyth.
She's announced that she'll be ending her streaming activities at the end of this month.
It's not a graduation though!
No, it's just, it will be the end of her current activities though.
You know, it's hard to say goodbye.
But we're wishing her the absolute best!
We'll treasure all the special memories we made together!
Not graduating.
But FUWAMOCO, you know, we really wish that we could have gotten to know Ame-senpai even better.
But the times that we did shit, you know, like we had the spelling bee!
And then a manga.
We were really super lucky to be able to have our first and last collab together with Ame-senpai!
Just the other day we solved some puzzles in Escape Simulator!
It's just like we had always dreamed of!
That was one of my big dreams.
They were a bit tricky too, huh?
Yeah, some of them really were, but... Good morning.
It was really fun.
I liked how Ame-senpai was like, FUWAMOCO, do you wanna do this part?
It was very nice.
We could've done very well, huh?
It was really fun sitting with the wand, though!
Please check it out if you haven't, okay?
Yeah, I saw there was one comment.
Oh, if Ame- If Ame-senpai, if she does this, she'll get it on the first try.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Everything that she's done that she's brought to us.
All of hololive English!
But she still has a very exciting week coming up.
Lots of really cool things.
Let's take a look.
There's a sketch meeting.
It's a little bit small, so it's hard to see here.
But obviously we have some Elden Ring Endurance streams coming up.
Wow, you know Ame-senpai was playing Elden Ring a lot then.
I guess maybe we're gonna see where that adventure goes even more.
And then there's gonna be a Valve multiplayer marathon too!
But, I guess more FUWAMOCO will be there when we play Team Fortress 2 and Garry's Mod as well.
There's gonna be a bunch of other Valve games being
Ocean Charity Stream
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Yeah, that will be really special too.
And then, on the 30th, on September 30th at 5pm PT.
That will be Ame-senpai's final stream there.
Make sure you don't miss it, okay Ruffians?
It might be hard sometimes, but let's all make sure to be able to say goodbye with a smile.
We'll smile!
Yeah, and of course, FUWAMOCO will be there watching the Miz Club and Abyss Senpai's final stream too, so...
Thank you for everything, everyone!
And I look forward to the remaining series that we have here together.
BAU BAU!
Let's make it really fun again!
We are FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians!
We did it!
We finally made our hologram debut!
If you're maybe wondering what exactly hologram is, the full title is holo no graffiti.
It's a very long running 3D anime that airs on the hololive official channel every week.
And by air I mean like there's a new episode.
But air sounds cooler.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
You're like a pondering butterfly!
You're definitely in nature, huh?
A pondering butterfly.
You're like me having a fever!
Fuwawa scream!
This is not anything like it.
That's probably it.
That's pretty it.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Within the 1 minute and 50 seconds, I think you can see just how much trouble and silliness that we could get into.
It was pretty close.
It was perfect.
BAU BAU!
If you like the part where we hug the most.
When was that?
I thought it was maybe that part.
Ruffians, if you haven't watched it yet, please go over to the official hololive channel!
Check it out and make sure to leave a comment on the episode just to let us know how much you liked seeing us in hololive!
Somehow, I don't know how it happened, but
hololive GTA.
The week long hololive GTA event.
It came to an end and it ended with a big bang!
Yeah!
Can we explain in case they don't know?
Well... We mentioned this lately before, but...
But the reason behind why FUWAMOCO Morning wasn't on last week was because of this very big event.
You know, all of hololive JP, ID, EN, device, it was that big event.
All of us were all participating in holo GTA.
Yeah, and it was our first time ever too!
Yeah, right!
We had no clue what to expect.
Yeah, you're still catching up.
There's a lot that went on.
There is a lot.
So many different perspectives.
A lot of chaos.
A lot of laughs.
Heartbreak.
Betrayal.
Everything.
Wow.
It has everything.
Yeah.
And of course explosions.
But to explain a bit more!
Yes!
Well, we moved to the town of Holosantos!
And we did our best working different professions.
You know, there was the gang.
And the police.
They had civilians like the bakery.
The cabaret.
You know the...
FUWAMOCO!
You'd think that we might have been working at the cat cafe.
But we became medics and we're working at the pillbox hospital!
Because, you know, this is a roleplay series.
So, you know, it's a bit different than normal life!
Yeah, but we're just a bit...
We are working under the head medic Fubuki-sensei!
Together with a bunch of other medics like Banjo-sensei, Ina-sensei, Iris-sensei, Iofi-sensei, Ririka-sensei.
It was a lot of fun, you know?
I don't know how it happened, but six hours every day.
It went by in no time.
Right!
Yeah, we did all our shifts too!
But by the end of it, we were really sad that it had
It was legendary, right?
We feel so honored to have been a part!
But it's sort of funny.
I already feel nostalgic now somehow.
You watched all the TV show!
We were the best doctors!
But you know the event, because you know it was with a JP-senpai and everything too.
The event was mainly in Japanese.
But we had Pero TL helping us translate the whole 7 day event live!
So please check out the archives if you weren't able to join us in the moment.
You know it was pretty crazy when it comes to different time zones and everything too.
So please check out
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
It's hard to pick a favorite while we keep on going.
What's your favorite moment?
I don't think we can really say it, but we picked some of our very special photos that we got to take during our time in Holosan for us.
This isn't from our perspective, but I think it's one of our favorite moments.
It's a bit of a spoiler, so if you don't want to know how the story ends, look away for now.
Turn off your headphones.
But!
Yeah.
This moment.
You know.
Wow.
I don't know!
Ruffians!
The three ended with that wedding!
You'd think that it was all scripted or something, but it was all live!
Just happening right then!
Coincidence after coincidence!
It was amazing!
Amazing wedding!
I don't know...
What a clean shot.
Yeah.
It was so good.
If you haven't been able to check it out, please find out why this happened.
The events leading up to it.
Yeah, and I think, you know, if you check out a clip from HoloGT, maybe sometimes it might be hard not to hear Fubuki-sensei being FUWAMOCO!
We had a lot of fun, right?
Yeah!
And you know, there's a bunch of different moments, you know?
As in our... Sort of explosive... Ambulance!
Yeah!
I know, yeah.
Gotta get to the scene as fast as you can.
And a couple incidents.
Yeah, sometimes you get back to the hospital so fast that the patient's no longer with you.
They're missing from your car.
That happened a couple times, huh?
A couple times?
Yeah.
This normal stuff.
We told them to wear their seatbelts!
We did every time!
We can't be helpful.
We can't help them if they don't wear their seatbelts.
Can't help them anymore than saying, put your seatbelt on.
Ruffians, I think you should know now.
Put your seatbelt on!
Got it?
Yeah.
Did you like it?
I liked our dog.
I liked it!
It was a challenge getting up the stairs.
It was a challenge in general!
Definitely didn't want anyone over.
We were smiling.
Yeah.
Smiling so much there was red all over the road.
So much lipstick.
Yeah.
It was fun and... I'm burger car!
Ultimate car is a burger car!
Does it count as a car?
It counts as a car.
Well, the honk button isn't a honk button.
There's no honk.
No what though?
What if it had jets so it could do more than just jump?
We'll never know!
What if it could've done more than jump and just fly?
Maybe?
Yeah, it had a boost.
And then Garibaldi appeared!
Don't care about Garibaldi!
You have to check it out, okay?
Garibaldi doesn't get hit by... Nothing.
Yeah.
Make sure you check it out, okay?
But it was just so much fun.
We're really happy to be able to get to know our senpai.
Also to have all of IAAN ID also included because you know it's really hard with multiple languages or language barriers.
Especially knowing you have the police, the gang.
You gotta hear some important instructions.
Is there anyone watching FUWAMOCO Morning for the first time?
Raise your hand!
BAU BAU!
There might be.
Liar.
FUWAMOCO!
I see some new hands now!
BAU BAU!
Thank you and welcome!
But you know, FUWAMOCO, whether in Holosantos or not, we'll continue to do our best to protect you so I am!
And no ambulances included this time.
No.
I miss it.
When I hear a clip and I hear the sounds down in my heart.
We really are so honored to have been apart.
I still don't get it.
It feels a little bit like a dream.
It's another week.
Another week all of a sudden.
Has it been a little bit of a struggle without FUWAMOCO Morning?
Do you need maybe a little bit of a Pup Talk?
Moco-chan, is there some words you could give us today?
Ruffians!
Do you know?
Do you know it's back?
Yeah!
Because this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me.
Mococo!
Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO Morning is back!
Did you miss it?
Well, you know, sometimes it's good to take a small break and then get back into your regular groove, you know?
We had fun in Holosantos together, but you know, it's also important to treasure our regular everyday as well.
So, let's all try to keep ourselves in tip-top shape and also try to do something that's a bit scary.
Maybe...
Everyday.
Cuz you never know what kind of amazing result you could have too.
Yes!
You can do it!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Let's do it best Ruffians again!
Let's take a look at some of the regular corners then!
Today we have a brand new Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is De-den!
Joey!
Cute boy!
Joey, you look so wise!
I guess what?
Tomorrow!
Tomorrow is Joey's birthday!
Happy birthday, Joey!
Happy birthday!
So cute fluffy!
Right?
Fluffy!
This means you know now Joey's gonna be getting even wiser.
That's a 10 out of 10 dog.
Yeah, I think so too.
Looks like Garibaldi.
This is Jolie.
This is Jolie, not Garibaldi.
Not Husky Miku.
Very different.
This is Jolie.
And tomorrow is Jolie's birthday, so happy birthday Jolie!
BAU BAU!
How does Jolie BAU BAU?
Sounds wise?
That's what I was going for.
Well, Julie, thank you for being a fan of FUWAMOCO!
Especially Mococo!
BAU BAU!
I'm gonna say make sure that you BAU BAU lots and not just when you see Moco-chan on the screen, okay?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
I got that one.
Not just when Pup Talks, okay?
FUWAMOCO!
Next we have our... Today I went on a walk with Ruffians!
Mane-chan!
Mane-chan wanted to let you know first that there's gonna be a spider in this next video.
So if you don't like spiders, look away, okay?
Let's take a look!
Oh!
Moco-chan!
Mane-chan tried to save you, but Moco-chan messed it up.
I messed it up!
Well, let's take a look now that we already saw the funky spider.
Okay, real spider.
You gotta get ready, okay?
Real spider now!
Just now, you didn't see it before.
Really funky but really cool, right?
It's also kind of funny.
It does look like a starfish but an angry one.
A starfish I do not want on me.
Really tastes like a starfish.
I would think it tastes like a spider.
I unfortunately have tasted that.
Camerafolding with RTX On!
Chuu!
Basically.
Yeah, just a little.
It's not good.
Yeah, but you know.
Yeah.
Definitely crypto money, chan.
Yeah, so it's just that good of a photo, you know?
Yeah, but is it fluffy or fuzzy though?
Let's decide together Moco-chan, okay?
Okay.
3, 2, 1.
Fuzzy!
Yeah, definitely fuzzy.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Stay away from it though.
I'm glad it didn't go on you.
BAU BAU!
And next we have a Question of the Day!
Moco-chan don't mess this one up okay?
We have a Question of the Day!
De-den!
What is Fuwawa's favorite Samuel character?
What is Mococo's favorite Samuel character?
Also, what are your favorite Pokemon?
Please let us know!
BAU BAU!
Good question.
No spiders this time.
Oh, I see some good guesses.
Fuwawa!
My favorite Samuel character is...
Has to be Pompompurin Oshinomobo!
Yeah, that one's very cute.
I like little twin stars.
Yeah.
Yeah, but Pompompurin's cute as well.
Yeah, it's a really good vibe, but... Little twin stars!
They can even say bad and their names in a sentence, Moco-chan.
What?
When did I do wrong?
BAU BAU!
It's not Sanrio, but we really like Pondylion too!
The best mascot!
Yeah!
But Pondylion is Pon-de-ring Mister Donut's mascot.
Yeah, we really like mascot characters.
But as for Pokemon, there's so many good Pokemon, but I really like Leporeon.
Yeah.
Moco-chan.
I like Alolan Raichu.
But you don't like Fluffy, right?
Not so much.
Yeah.
We're not gonna get too angry at Fluffy though because otherwise Fluffy's gonna get us back and that's gonna be scary.
Right, Moco-chan?
FUWAMOCO was scary last time, right?
Last FUWAMOCO Morning, right?
I love and like you!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for your submissions!
Remember, FUWAMOCO Morning is always something that we make together, so thank you for being here with us!
We're always looking forward to more doggy of a days!
To be seeing the walks that you've been going on.
Hopefully you don't see spiders.
Maybe you might be seeing the change in color of the leaves soon.
Hopefully no peril amongst those leaves, you know?
So please let us know!
You can use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Okay, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
EDF!
We played all together last week and we got pretty strong.
Pretty good at defending the earth but not strong enough to have our senpai join us in game.
So we're gonna go back and we're gonna see just how strong we can be with Advent plus hololive English senpai with me.
BAU BAU!
Please join us!
And put a schedule!
After that, on Tuesday we're playing a game called Urayama.
Gonna go deep into the Japanese countryside.
And we're gonna have some nice fun.
I hope I don't see anything frightening.
Not anything too frightening.
My heart is sort of scary.
We'll see how it goes.
Hopefully, at the very least, it's beautiful!
Yeah!
I'm excited!
We have FUWAMOCO Morning followed by Ame-senpai's Valve Game Marathon!
Yeah!
We're gonna be doing a Team Fortress 2.
First time Team Fortress 2 for us!
And then Garry's Mod together with everybody.
Garry's Mod was so much fun!
Yeah!
And we played it for Myth's third anniversary too.
It's funny.
In case you don't know, it's like hide and seek.
Yeah, it was really fun.
And then on Saturday we're having our Rock n' Rawr Party!
This is how we're gonna end our summer, Ruffians!
This is the end of summer, okay?
You know, get your water gun all loaded up.
Some nice drinks on screen.
And let's have a summer party, okay?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
And then after that a homework day for us so we're gonna do our best to take a little bit of a moment to be able to get some more sleep and some more work done.
We're the Ruffians who are joining us to the archive today!
Here is your FUWAMOCO with... It's...
BAU BAU AMBULANCE!
BAU BAU AMBALANCE!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
We've!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!